looking forward to 2024
more and more Republicans are saying
Donald Trump's not going to be the
Republican nominee now I'm able to find
no data that points that way but let's
take it a step at a time as I like to do
and start with the claims that are being
made there's an article on the hill
from this morning growing number of
Republicans say Trump won't be the
Republican nominee
former speaker Paul Ryan
former Florida Governor Jeb Bush former
vice president Mike Pence in recent days
each indicated they'd rather see someone
else on the ballot in the next
presidential election
some of the most outspoken figures like
Ryan Bush and congresswoman Liz Cheney
are no longer standard bearers of the
party which has been taken over by Trump
exactly but they still carry large
megaphones there are concerns about
another term candidacy combined with
polls showing many voters are ready to
move on illustrate how Trump's viability
as a candidate could shape how the
primary comes into Focus
former house Speaker Newt Gingrich said
some people like Trump and some people
don't like Trump he's the most dominant
single figure in the party and that's a
fact we played the clip a few days ago
of Mike Pence saying well there might be
somebody else I'd prefer more when he
was asked about supporting Trump in 24
Pence may be planning to run himself
uh Paul Ryan speaking about 24 says I
think Trump's unelectability will be
palpable by then we all know he will
lose or let me put it this way we all
know he's much more likely to lose the
White House than anybody else running
for president on us our side of the
aisle so why would we want to go with
that
and then you could find other people Joe
O'Day the Republican Senate candidate in
Colorado says I don't think Trump should
run again Mitch McConnell has kind of
played Coy with it uh Lindsey Graham
says we have a pretty good chance uh
with with Trump running but pretty good
chance isn't necessarily the best thing
so the most important question is how
are they going to stop him if he runs
they can barely stand up to him now when
he's not even running for anything do we
really imagine them standing up to Trump
after he announces not really do we
imagine them standing up to Trump after
he survives longer than a few other
candidates who start to drop out in the
support consolidates around Trump the
way we saw it in 2016. I don't know that
I see it and most importantly look at
the polling data that we have 2024
presidential nomination we have polling
from uh from this month there's a New
York Times Siena poll from this month
there's a Harris poll from this month in
the New York Times Siena poll Trump is
lead leading by 23.
with DeSantis at 26 so it's Trump 49
DeSantis 26. in the Harris poll Trump is
leading by 38. that doesn't really look
like Republican voters are ready to
abandon Trump if you look at the betting
markets the betting markets those are
asking the question not who do you
support in 24 but who do you believe
will win it's basically a dead heat
between DeSantis and Trump so the most
optimistic data we can find is that the
betting markets at predictit.org say
it's basically a toss-up but then you
also look at some of the other latest
polling and this is polling on
hypothetical matchups now this is who
could win who could win in 2024 there
there is an argument maybe for someone
other than Trump because you look at
recent polling Emerson College says if
the race were today Biden beats Trump by
three Yahoo news if the race is today
Biden beats Trump by two
um so the best case would be there isn't
great polling for Trump winning in a
rematch but it is very early and there's
almost 15 12 12 to 14 undecided when you
pull people today
part of me wants Trump to run
because there's a real chance that
DeSantis would fare better against the
eventual Democratic nominee at the same
time crazy things can happen and anybody
can end up winning as we have learned
and as we have seen so it's really up to
Republicans I don't have advice for them
I think Trump is uh vulnerable if he is
the nominee
but maybe that's a reason that we want
to see him run if we're looking from the
left but the most important question to
the Republicans and it's up to them to
figure it out I'm not giving them advice
if you really don't want Trump to run or
you don't want him to be the nominee
what can you actually do to dissuade
Republican voters from supporting him
because as of right now there's clear
support behind only one candidate and
that's Trump there's a smaller but still
statistically significant amount of
support behind DeSantis no one else is
polling greater than five or six percent
I know we're two years away but I don't
understand how they stop Trump if Trump
wants it let me know your thoughts